[Music]
while Max is certainly back in Mad Max
fury road hi I'm Mike Zimmer from ethics
guide.com for Wired
and while the film has amazing stunts an
incredible cinematography in a film with
some 2,400 shots a staggering 2,000 of
them are still VFX shots and they work
with some of the most creative film
color grading and look development yet
attempted Mad Max was shot primarily in
Africa with real vehicles and complex
that's an incredibly choreographed
camerawork but to allow such amazing
stunts meant there was a fair amount of
safety rig removal but to really make
the scenes cinematic a massive amount of
environment work was done along with
some innovative color grading and some
pretty good armed removal the approach
of Mad Max was to film in-camera and to
combine takes and elements as much as
possible
this meant that some things that might
have seemed like CGI to an experienced
eye were really green screen but the
epic nature of the film was also greatly
enhanced by building complex and
beautiful environments around those
live-action plates and when the live
action was not possible
full CGI environments were made such as
the Citadel even the CGI storm still had
live-action elements that were shot and
combined by the primary effects house
Allura not only did the environments get
added but the whole film had a rich
grade that was as innovative as it was
original if you look at the early PR
shots from onset you'll get an insight
into how the film had originally planned
to look in addition to just grading the
film in a much richer saturated way a
huge number of the shots had sky
replacements done as part of the grade
which is unusual but perhaps not as
unexpected as the decision to shoot the
film's night sequences as overexposed
shots in the day one would think that
filming a night shot would require
anything but overexposed full daylight
but thanks to an innovative approach
that VFX supervisor Andrew Jackson
pitched to oscar-winning DOP John seal
the team filmed the night sequences
overexposed
not lose any of the shadow detail like
under the rigs
and then thanks to the dynamic range of
the amazing Arri Alexa camera
they then squashed down the daylight
footage but proportionately more in the
highlights and then tinted all the
footage blue seal joke that other dear
Peas he spoke to thought he was the mad
one but Jackson thought of this approach
after misfiring with some of his own
digital stills and then trying to fix
them one night after shooting the result
of the sky replacement innovative
grading an extensive environment work
and some hardcore ston action has made
Mad Max fury road a breakout hit well
don't forget to subscribe for more
technical behind the scenes action I'm
like semi for wide
[Music]